i don't know do you enjoy league or do
you feel like
league of legends by the way yeah of
course do you actually enjoy
league or do you just sometimes play it
because it's just like
it's it's it's like a familiar kind of
like system that you just understand
and i think i don't know jerry probably
hasn't had this but
i think when you've played a game like
that for so long
there's just kind of like almost
autopilot nature to it where like i'll
see i have like an hour free
yeah and i'll just click it open even
though every time i know when i click it
open it's a bad idea because
not only one will i probably not have a
good game even if i have a good game i
don't feel good about it cause i'm like
well that was a stomp that was no fun
yeah if i lose or have someone hinting
or on the japanese server i've been
playing
people just [ __ ] troll so much more
yeah it's so bad
and i'll be like well i just wasted 30
minutes and now i'm [ __ ] angry
and then i know every time i click it
open i'm not going to it's never going
to be worth it but sometimes i still do
it yeah
it's because it's like just habit
building i i have played league of
legends
like it's been like my i'd say my main
game yeah
god when did lucian come out like 2004
jesus christ man like it's been like six
six seven years i've just like it's been
my the game that i always should go back
to
yeah right and it used to be really fun
but now it's just like depressing
like and that's why i like it's it's so
funny
speaking to people who've played league
for years because everyone talks about
it like there are [ __ ] drug addicts
like it's still awesome you know i just
i want to quit
but i just can't man i just can't i need
just something about me
there's something about me just like i i
just need to play one more game just one
more game
but i just can't quit i can't quit damn
it
it used to be uh like back when i lived
in
and when i was in university it was
really easy to just play with people
and it was pretty fun because i was used
to play for the university team as well
yeah
it was pretty fun actually i really
enjoyed that yeah um but then when i
left university
i went to london i i wasn't really
playing as much with friends
and then i sent the move to japan it's
it's totally like a solo queue thing oh
it just isn't fun
which solo queue is just playing on your
own with four other random people
and i don't know why in the japanese
server it's so bad dude
it's really it's full of like chinese
smurfs and korean smurfs who wanted to
[ __ ] around
so all the things are horrible so then
have you considered
quitting stopping it's hard because
because
it's because i know why it's because
there's nothing to replace it what do
you do right what do you do when you
have like
like just one hour free just only one
hour three jack off
for one hour i mean
i'll i'll get the job done within that
hour right and then
connor's like that's an unoptimized jack
off you can't have that
or you know jackoff should take more
than five minutes oh then yeah i have 55
minutes to do whatever i want all right
but like okay no but what do you do like
read a book watch something like
read it read a book usually i can't open
a book for an hour it's like
because you're [ __ ] monkey brains
it's like an eight-hour thing for me if
i open a book eight hours
i can i have to make it a whole day
thing if i read
i'm talking i'm talking about like like
mango mango
it has to be a whole day thing i can't
put it down yeah i i can't oh no i can
easily just pick up a volume reader and
then that's it yeah
because i think the problem is is that
league is so easy to just do
for 30 minutes it's it's engaging it
just it just engages that monkey brain
that [ __ ] lizard brain where you're
just like okay i'm just clicking buttons
now and i recognize
that it invalidates a lot of my points
like when we talked about fighting games
yeah
that clip of us talking about it and me
being like yeah
you know i got so much [ __ ] for that
because one first of all they were like
well conor's a league player so it makes
so much sense yeah and the other top
comments are like
conor's just a sore loser that's why he
doesn't like fighting games i'm like
you don't know a true [ __ ] loss until
you played a 40-minute game of league
and your team [ __ ] threw it all i
would rather lose a two-minute fighting
game
any day of the week than lose one league
game because it is [ __ ] brutal
i mean just from the sounds of it it
just sounds like a [ __ ] experience oh it
is it's terrible it's [ __ ] off then
stop who knows
no because just say that to a crack
addict joey
[Music]
you could quit crack just do league it
is it is like crack because i will say
like
the the honeymoon period of league like
when
when you first start learning the game
and when you start clicking
it's like it's probably like one of my
some of my fondest gaming experiences in
my life when i'm just like yeah
this is a really really fun game and
it's just like it is
i didn't even get to that point yeah
because i played one game and then five
minutes in all the comments said
called me new kicked me so so tell me
like what did you hate about league of
legends like walk me through it
i mean well first of all i don't like
mobas to begin with yeah i mean
so yeah so yeah so that was that and
then just
again like just from what i've seen and
from what i've heard
from a distance the league community
just looks like a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] like
it's like it's like it's it's like what
do you mean by a bunch
like it's like they just you know i've
i've never i've i've always hated using
the word
gatekeeping yeah but my god league
players
are like the crowns of gatekeeping like
you say anything bad about the game you
you try and you know get into it
like with no experience or like no
knowledge of the game whatsoever
most communities will you know at least
a few of them will be like
hey you're trying to get into our game
welcome we'll we'll we'll invite you
with open arms but if you suck at the
game then that's your responsibility
right and i'm like all right fair enough
yeah but meanwhile league is like you're
not a [ __ ] god at this game from five
minutes in then you're a [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
get out it's it's that's that was my
experience with i mean league definitely
has
one of the most toxic communities yeah
yeah
i i actively tell people like just don't
get into league
yeah it's not like i'm like it's not
rewarding yeah and i'm like i i already
can't deal with
[ __ ] toxic communities to begin with
yeah i don't really mind that much
like i kind of like that aspect of game
i've been on the internet for too long i
don't want to deal with that [ __ ]
anymore
conor's like a toxic gamer in himself i
have to deal with the anime community
right like
let alone the league community i don't
know what do you think about the
argument that like
a lot of people get really upset with
the idea of like trash talking video
games online like what do you think
about that
i think if it's done tastefully i don't
really yeah like whenever i see
trash talking like the fighting game
community i'm like that's that's just
fun
yeah it's like yeah it's kind of it's
kind of sad because i feel like in
league of legends
not i mean it's obviously there are some
people who say some [ __ ] abhorrent
stuff
yeah but like i think just you know like
[ __ ] telling the other team they're
bad and stuff is funny as hell
yeah exactly exactly if it's done
tasteful yeah right and which is there's
many ways to do that i mean
yeah as long as you're not like
attacking someone personally yeah yeah
yeah
i think it's like i'm all game for it
like if someone if i do a terrible like
job in a league of legends game
actually [ __ ] sign up i [ __ ] hope
they type in they all
all chat to me saying like yeah lol or
something you know what i mean
because that's funny to me like want
that because you'd do the same right oh
yeah but if it gets to like you know
some racial xenophobic [ __ ] then i'm
just like all right
yeah at least obviously i think i think
there's a draw on the line but obviously
kind of feels like especially in league
that they've like kind of like cracked
down on anything like that
but i feel like they had to because it
was so far
removed from what was acceptable that
you're like
you you go into like a normal game and
people are still toxic as [ __ ] even
though it's a [ __ ] normal game
the problem was that they never enforced
any of the rules for so long so it just
kept escalating
yeah i reckon if they enforced like the
actual rules from the beginning it
wouldn't have been so bad
all right i mean yeah but i feel like
this is like the same cycle for
every competitive game and i mean
without exception i mean you look like
i played overwatch yeah you look at
overwatch the first the first few months
great everyone had [ __ ] fun everyone
was just learning the game
and then like it's it's it's the problem
of like
when you've played and played the game
enough you don't play because it's fun
you play it because like you said it's
just something to do and then out from
the shadows or rose the tryhards
dude i could i had some of the worst
experiences of my life on overwatch
did you actually because league of
legends right it's bad right it's bad
it's it's
you see them violet [ __ ] but at least
there's no voice chat
in overwatch you're automatically put in
like voice chat yeah that sounds
horrible
well okay sometimes you'd have like the
funniest moments ever like you would
meet the coolest people
and it was like you'd always have to
remember that whenever you got like the
10 games in a row of like [ __ ] kids
and [ __ ] right yeah
because like as well the worst part is
in overwatch
when i used to play it they implemented
a system now where you can queue up for
a role
but it used to be six of you get put in
you all might be six tank mains you all
might be six
like dps mains and so you just stop
[ __ ] bickering immediately
yeah over who gets what yeah and that's
why i always should play fill in games
like i'll just do whatever because i'm
like i don't [ __ ] care like don't
don't shout at me let's just do it man
yeah but man people would like say
horrible [ __ ] on that like always 12
year olds as well i mean because once
you
once you once you play it enough hours
then you've reached this point where
you're like okay i got to play ranked
because
otherwise playing this game is kind of
like meaningless in a sense right i hate
playing normal games of like competitive
games yeah but one
but then when once you start getting on
the ranks ladder is when i
find it it stops getting fun because
then you reach everyone reaches a wall
doesn't matter who you are everyone will
reach a wall eventually and once you
reach that wall
you just feel like you stop progressing
unless you put like
so many hours into learning this game
and trying to better yourself and that
and and that
and at that point i understand why
people get toxic and angry yeah because
then that
way they're like to invest into like
making that right like climbing up the
ranks ladder and everything so they feel
like they
need this to feel like they they haven't
wasted their time which
let's be honest unless you're a pro
gamer you probably are wasting your time
with it no
that might be i think it's just the
simple thing that i'm just not
into pvp with random people really i
think that's all it is
like i'm thinking about it now i'm like
i've never enjoyed just pvp games to
begin with
maybe for the exception of like some
fighting games but only if i'm like
playing it with friends
i know right so like i'll play like a
game of smash or like street fighter or
tekken or whatever
if i'm sitting in the same room with you
and we're just like having a fun [ __ ]
time right
but i think just the whole idea of pvp
against randos on the internet who i
don't know or care about i think that's
just the one thing i [ __ ] hate in
life has gone laughing i i just i just
have this like
image of joey being like i i have fun
with i have fun with friends
and i think like the angriest i've ever
seen joey
is when when you're playing against
conor and he was like spamming king k
rool
your house and i'm just like but that's
the thing right but that's the thing
it's that i'm okay with getting angry in
situations like that
because i know connor right and he's
there
in front of me right like so like that's
just fun times right like yeah i was
pissed off that you were a
spamming [ __ ] counselor with king k
rool every [ __ ] match
joey gets very very angry when he loses
in the smash
yeah that's what i'm saying it's like i
already don't
like pvp games as it is like i'm not a
huge fan of pvp as it is because i get
angry easily
but especially when it's against people
i can't see or i've never heard of
never talked to just don't know yeah
that that anger i think
yeah that's that just like the enjoyment
is just completely gone
i remember you were like yeah man i'm
the no one's beating me in mario kart
ever
like joey's like i did not say that
you're like you're like i never lose in
mario kart dude the absolute slanders
and then i was like bet and then like
joey would beat all his friends and i
would just [ __ ] crush
okay crush is a strong word in recent
times we've been playing and it's been
pretty 50 50. but yeah
when it was like which one was it it's
probably when deluxe came out the new
mario kart 8 i was [ __ ] killing you
yeah i think so
and had like made like uh crank game
plays ethan have like a [ __ ]
breakdown
do you remember that we did like a
stream where we oh we kept playing mario
kart
i only played baby park for like five
hours until
until ethan could beat me and we must
have played it you have like five
hours until i until he managed to be
like we did like a hundred and fifty
[ __ ]
we did maybe [ __ ] 150 times on stream
we're like all right let's like after
like race 20 we were like all right if
ethan beats connor
in one race then we'll end this stream
yeah and then that was also earlier on
that they they thought i was cheating or
something
yeah doom was like he's got a modded
switch or something like he's winning
too many times so they made us all
change
the same character in the same car and
everything like so that there was no no
cheating
he was like how are you still beating me
every time